what if you dug a hole through the earth
what would it take how fast could you
travel to the other side of the earth
how deep if we made it already this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you dug a hole through the earth we all
heard the rumor as kids that tunneling
through the earth would take us to the
other side of the world sorry to crush
your dreams it doesn't really work that
way most people would end up in the
middle of an ocean if they tried digging
through the earth it may work in some
places if you lived in Beijing then
you'd surface in Argentina and from
Madrid it's a direct route to New
Zealand but how far would you get if you
could dig a tunnel through the earth it
would be seven thousand nine hundred and
eighteen miles long and if you jumped
right in it would only take you 45
minutes to reach the opposite side of
the earth of course in all the
excitement you might forget to grab onto
something once you popped out at which
point you'd fall right back to where you
started so far human digging has only
made it point one percent of the way
through the earth in the 70s and 80s the
Soviets attempted to drill as deep as
they could into the Earth's crust
they made it down forty thousand two
hundred thirty feet before temperatures
of 570 degrees melted their equipment
but with a magic shovel a super
heat-resistant suit and some special
boots to hold your footing on molten
rock you might fare a little better the
Earth's interior is composed of four
layers the outermost shell is called the
crust which runs about thirty miles deep
and for every point six miles of depth
the temperature goes up seventy-seven
degrees the average human would suffer
hyperthermia after the first mile but
since you're so well-equipped you get to
dig down to the mantle digging through
this layer would be a particular
challenge since it makes up over 80
percent of our planet's volume and it's
all hot liquid rock also known as the
asthenosphere this layer is responsible
for tectonic plate movement and it's the
reason why we have mountains volcanoes
and earthquakes not only would it be a
sluggish task to dig through thousands
of miles of molten rock you may have to
dodge a shifting continent in the
process eventually you'll make it to the
cooler layer
an ironic descriptor since the
temperatures at Earth's outer core
ranged between 7200 and 9,000 degrees
this layer won't be any easier to get
through than the mantle since it's a
shell of liquid iron but try out to do
too much damage with your digging the
outer core gives our planet its magnetic
field and we can't live without it
finally you get to the inner core and
it's probably where you should consider
ending your journey we're not quitters
at what F but we do care about your
well-being and take our word for it
digging through the Earth's core would
not be fun the inner core is essentially
a large white hot ball of solid iron and
nickel it's solid because the pressure
from 3218 miles below the earth's
surface is so great it prevents the iron
from melting so with every scoop of your
shovel the liquid iron from the outer
core would simply fill in the empty gaps
and solidify in order to make it through
you'd have to work much faster than is
humanly possible but that's no challenge
here the challenge however might be
mastering the floating dig with a
significant amount of the Earth's mass
above you countering the force of
gravity from the rest of the world you'd
be rendered completely weightless
hence the floating dig but with
unlimited time anything is possible and
somehow you make it through the core
your journey out of the center of the
earth would be even harder since gravity
would be pulling you backwards the whole
way through when you finally break
ground on the opposite end of the earth
assuming you don't surface in the middle
of an ocean then you better be satisfied
because the way back would certainly be
closed so that's one way to travel and
we mean one way literally please do not
try this at home if you want to travel
across the world buy a piggy bank save
your lucky pennies and someday you'll
get there it may take longer than 45
minutes but don't let that stop you from
dreaming stay curious keep asking
questions and of course we'll keep
digging for you
[Music]
you